welcome back to our emmy's extravaganza
the emmy celebrate television stars but
today we wanted to celebrate the stars
of our show that we called drew gooders
so we took our six feet from 600
game to hollywood with two very
deserving contestants and a surprise
twist take a look
[Applause]
hey everyone we're here at the tcl
chinese theater on historic hollywood
boulevard otherwise known as the walk of
fame
we're gonna do a special emmys edition
of our show
and we're gonna play everyone's favorite
social distance game show
60 from
600.00 we have two contestants playing
today i would like you to meet alicia
and jerry
now jerry you're gonna be up first okay
and alicia we're gonna see you in one
minute jerry is a preschool teacher
now i understand that during the
pandemic
you actually drove a school bus around
for a certain reason will you tell me
about that so my school closed down
and i didn't know what my next step was
going to be and i stumbled across a bus
on facebook marketplace
and then i converted it into a mobile
classroom and now i teach children in my
community
in their driveways and at parks and i i
teach out of this really groovy bus
so
jerry really quickly before we get
started you have a little thing on your
podium yes um do you mind actually
sticking it on the back wall right next
to the 600.
it's six feet from six thousand
thank you jerry
that you're welcome absolutely perfect
no jerry this is all about you and we
want you to win and today every question
is going to be emmy related we're going
to put 60 seconds on the clock
in the handmaid's tale what color are
the dresses of the handmaids they're
required to wear red red or black blue
black
red or black red thank you
what is sterling k brown's character's
name and this is us is it randall
pearson or jack pearson jeff pearson
randall pearson yes
[Music]
okay
tell cersei i want to know it was me is
a famous line from which show
the crown or game of thrones g-o-t thank
you
okay pose star billy porter appeared on
the drew barrymore show singing to what
a sandwich or a flower
a flower
oh my god i love this show so much in
penn 15 is the lead actors they play 13
year olds but how old are they in real
life 21 or 31
31 31 yeah good you got it you got it
all right time's up
okay i feel like that's my bad like i
took too long not your fault thank you
for playing
hi
okay this show should be called six feet
from a scorching sun
it's a little hot but it's okay icarus
now alicia first of all i want to ask
what do you do for a living so i have
the pleasure of helping people to live
out their dreams and their passions by
helping them start non-profits
so everything from working
working with the homeless to
youth mentoring programs you name it we
do it in fact right now we've got a
backpack supply and food drive going on
in watts california for over 300
families that otherwise would not have
been able to have school supplies
so well
um i'm gonna donate my own six thousand
dollars to that program oh my god
thank you thank you
absolutely your category is all about
the walk of fame okay kind of where we
are right now yes let's see if you can
win six thousand dollars all right here
we go ready and okay which 11 time emmy
winner's name was misspelled on their
star in 2010 julie louise dreyfus or
jerry seinfeld julie bowie striker yes
true false emmy nominee anthony anderson
star is located across the street from
his old high school true no fault yes no
you were right that's true which talk
show host is located right in front of
us literally his studio is right across
the street fallon or kimmel kimbo yes
harry belafonte became the first black
performer to win an emmy and also got a
walk of fame start this same year the
year was 1960 or 1950. 1960. that's
right
this emmy-winning family is one of few
fictional characters with a walk of fame
and stars is it the simpsons or the
griffins from family guy the simpsons
yes sure balls the iconic boxer and emmy
winner muhammad ali star is the only one
mounted on a wall rather than the ground
it's true
[Applause]
that's twelve thousand dollars
there you go six feet apart that's right
there you go thank you
it's for you
and if i only had another one i would
show it to the backpack program uh maybe
i can give you this one for the backpack
program actually i'm gonna have to give
it to jerry
thank you
next time i'll go faster and i'll get
you there but nonetheless you're going
home with six thousand dollars
thank you and guess what that's six
that's twelve that's eighteen thousand
dollars right here
[Applause]
[Music]
with our favorite game show six feet
from six hundred or 6 000.
[Applause]
[Music]
well congrats jerry and alicia we love
you and we'll be right back
[Music]
you